everything everything is great about
doctor in England you have people like
their grandparents watch did their
parents watch it now they watch it I
love that no matter what you like or
what you're interested in there's a
doctor for you or a time period or a
story or a companion and it's just you
know it's escapism it's a different
world the Fourth Doctor is so cool and
he would just whip these out to make
friends with his enemies don't look like
babies the Fourth Doctor picks orange so
I'm gonna make orange mm-hmm
they're squishy on the inside very
chalky it tastes medicine II this powder
is making me want to cough I've totally
Tom Baker these jelly babies up Danny
knows the TARDIS self-destruct button oh
man Matt Smith he's my man he was my
first doctor he's better taste as good
as they look if it was really a Doctor
Who food though it would have two hearts
not crazy Bob I could see how they taste
better with the fez on though mm-hmm our
teeth I like it it's not too sweet this
is nice and chewable and young tastic
mm-hmm
this looks nasty
is it weird the my mother cries well it
was like the only thing he found
palatable after in his regeneration so
I'm assuming it's not gonna be that
strong of a flavor a little afraid I'm
not a fish person
I do like fish fingers I do like custard
I'm so happy right now
hmm I'm less happy now mmm
but strangely Xiao chuan custards not
good you guys if you've definitely had
to have just regenerated to watch this
my gosh one of my favorite episodes -
the perfect that these are snack because
when you see them in the show you just
want to eat them up because they're so
cute and fluffy they should have just
eaten the adipose when I came out of
their body that would have solved the
whole problem right are they gonna burst
out of me if I eat this like in the show
yeah go ahead how does a little chubby
little arm mm-hmm who knew fat could be
so tasty everything is dusted with
space-time ripple apart that just walks
away jammie Dodger adipose s'mores
trying the food from the show is like
getting a whole new experience that the
TV show just can't do for you I feel
closer to the doctor now